[Musik]
Dieser Podcast wird Ihnen von der LMU
München sehr gut präsentiert, also hallo alle zusammen, also hat
Nina bereits alle Geschichten erzählt, die
ich Ihnen erzählen wollte, also möchte ich
hier über eines von mehreren Themen sprechen
, auf die ich mich konzentrieren werde  Einige
ethische Fragen, die
durch das Phänomen Antibiotikaresistenz aktualisiert werden.
Ich werde das in gewisser Weise tun. Ich
werde auch ein wenig einführen,
was Antibiotikaresistenz, was Arzneimittelresistenz
im Allgemeinen ist, also haben Sie
all diese Begriffe in diesem Bereich  Die meisten von
Ihnen haben wahrscheinlich davon gehört, dass
sie die Schlüsselresistenz oder
Antibiotikaresistenz zuordnen, dies und dies und
die mikrobielle Resistenz ist ein hoffnungsloser
Begriff, den die Weltorganisation
verwendet, was bedeuten soll, dass
jedes Medikament, das Sie verwenden, auf eine
Art abzielt  des Krankheitserregers irgendeine Art von
Mikroorganismus, der die menschliche Gesundheit schädigen kann
das Virus Pilz oder was auch immer für
jedes dieser Arzneimittel Resistenzen
entwickelt werden können, aber die häufigste Art von
Resistenz, und in diesem Moment ist
die schwerwiegendste die biotische
Resistenz. So oft, wenn wir von Arzneimittelresistenz sprechen,
meinen wir in der Praxis,
wenn wir Resistenz gegen Antibiotika haben, und wenn wir
darüber sprechen, ist natürlich, dass diese
Mikroorganismen, die Bakterien,
resistent werden  gegenüber den Drogen ist nicht, dass die
Leute resistent werden gegen die
Drogen oder so etwas, das ist also
nur eine kleine Einführung, auf
diese Weise werde ich ein wenig über
die technische Seite davon sprechen, dass ich nicht in der
Medizin bin  weder im Gesundheitswesen noch
bin ich ein Philosoph, aber ich habe viel
mit angewandten Themen gearbeitet. Ich stehle auch ein
bisschen Wissen von meinen mehr und
den Leuten in diesem Zentrum, dass ich Porto bin,
aber dann werde ich es tun  Konzentrieren Sie sich
genauer auf die Beziehung zwischen
wie und Reinheitswiderstand
die Bedingungen der Gesundheitsversorgung und
Gesundheitssysteme im Allgemeinen umgestalten können und wie
sich dies auf die Standardvorstellungen bezieht, die
wir in der medizinischen Ethik haben, wie wir uns verhalten sollen  Die
Verantwortung als Arzt oder als Krankenschwester oder
wir eine andere Art von professioneller Hilfe
in der medizinischen Ethik, das wird mein
Vortrag sein, und dann werde ich
es ein wenig problematisieren und am Ende ein wenig darüber sprechen,
wie Sie es könnten
Lösen Sie diese Dilemmata, die aufzutauchen scheinen,
wenn wir haben, was Sie tun könnten,
um die
Herausforderung oder Bedrohung durch Antibiotikaresistenzen zu bekämpfen, wenn Sie möchten, und
gleichzeitig werden Sie versuchen, eine
Art Standardregeln der
medizinischen Ethik zu respektieren, könnten Sie das tun?
Gleichzeitig bin ich mir nicht sicher, aber ich werde ein wenig darüber sprechen, also wenn
jemand von
Ihnen eine spezifischere
Frage hat, die meisten Kotori-Fragen,
winken Sie einfach mit der Hand und ich versuche, etwas zu beantworten
, das Sie nicht interessiert  zu etwas,
aber danach werden wir viel
Zeit für Fragen und Antworten haben
, also fangen wir hier an, mit ihnen
über Arzneimittelresistenzen zu sprechen, also ist es ein
schnell zunehmendes und sich ausbreitendes
Phänomen, so dass sowohl immer mehr
Arten von Bakterien entstehen  resistent
gegen immer mehr Arten von Antibiotika, so
verlorenes Jahr haben wir die ersten gemeldeten
Fälle von sogenannten Lost-Resort-
Antibiotika, also sind dies die Antibiotika
, die Sie verwenden, wenn Sie alle
anderen Arten ausprobiert haben und sie nicht wirken, weil
die Bakterien resistent sind  Noch schlimmer als
dies ist das, was Sie oft als
Carbapeneme bezeichnen, also haben Sie letztes Jahr in China den ersten
gemeldeten Fall von Resistenz gegen diese
Art, aber es
breitet sich sehr schnell bei den
otischen Resistenzbakterienstämmen oder Spirituosen aus,
wo
so schnell wie ein Flugticket kann
Sie nehmen Sie um die Welt, weil sie
mit uns reisen und sie
reisen mit unserem Essen und so weiter. Sie
können also sehen, dass es sehr schnell geht. Gleichzeitig ist
ein weiterer Aspekt, dass sich gleichzeitig
sehr schnell Widerstände entwickeln  Auf der ganzen
Welt haben Sie einen Rückgang in der Produktion
neuer Antibiotika-Formulierungen, und ich werde
ein wenig darüber sprechen, also eine
Sache, die so tatsächlich helfen könnte  In der
Welt der Arzneimittel und pharmakologischen
Behandlungen haben Sie
aufgrund der Evolution diesen ständigen Wettlauf mit der Natur,
und eine Möglichkeit, den Wettlauf zu gewinnen
, besteht darin, immer wieder neue Arzneimittelformeln
zu finden, um der Entwicklung von Resistenzen einen Schritt voraus zu sein,
aber wenn Sie die
Innovation auf dieser Seite am Laufen haben  Wenn
Sie die Kurven nach oben gehen,
haben Sie dieses Problem, und wenn Sie möchten,
können Sie zur Weltgesundheitsorganisation gehen.
Sie haben viele gute Tage.
Sie haben gerade einen neuen Bericht über die
globale Überwachung hier veröffentlicht, also die globale
Überwachung  Das Fehlen, das sind nur
fünfundzwanzig Prozent der Länder der Welt,
die sich jetzt an
der Überwachung beteiligen, aber es nimmt auch
sehr schnell zu. Am Ende
des Vortrags werden Sie viele Links finden
, die ich Ihnen hier oben lassen
werde  Schauen Sie sich das richtig an, also wenn Sie es sich ansehen, also
das ist Arzneimittelresistenz, was ist die Herausforderung der Arzneimittelresistenz.
Ich denke, das
erste, woran die Leute denken, ist diese Idee, also
lesen Sie vielleicht das  Papiere über den
Supervirus, der uns alle umbringen wird,
also diese Idee einer Epidemie, gegen die wir
uns nicht wehren können, daran
denken die Leute natürlich als Erstes
, und natürlich unsere Wohlfahrtsgesellschaften
und modernen Häuser, die auf diesem
Rückgrat ruhen  Dass wir Epidemien kontrollieren können
, ist eines der Rückgrate moderner
zivilgesellschaftlich verwirklichter Gesellschaften, das wir
mit Hilfe der sanitären Einrichtungen, aber auch
mit Hilfe von Antibiotika und
Impfungen und Aufklärungsmenschen dazu gebracht haben,
Infektionskrankheiten so zu kontrollieren, dass die Menschen
nicht so erkranken  krank wie früher und
sie werden viel weniger krank und wenn
sie krank werden, können wir sie behandeln und wir
gehen. Das Problem ist natürlich, dass
wir viele Leute haben, die die ganze Zeit krank werden und
nicht zur Arbeit gehen können  Ich habe
die Wirtschaft geschädigt, all die
Ressourcen geschädigt, die man braucht, um das Gesundheitssystem zu betreiben,
die ganze Gesellschaft bricht
irgendwie auseinander, deshalb ist das
natürlich wichtig, aber es ist nicht nur
das.  Ein
Teil dieser Herausforderung ist der andere, dass,
auch wenn wir glauben, dass wir keine
großen Epidemien bekommen, viele Dinge, die
wir heute in Krankenhäusern tun, davon abhängen
, dass wir so gut wie Zugang zu wirksamen
Antibiotika haben  Alle Arten von offenen
Operationen Ich meine, offene Operationen wären
tausendmal gefährlicher,
als wenn wir keine Antibiotika hätten,
denn natürlich ist das Infektionsrisiko sofort enorm, wenn Sie den Körper öffnen,
selbst wenn Sie gute
sanitäre Einrichtungen haben und besonders von  natürlich
Transplantationschirurgie, wo wir
auch eine Transplantation ermöglichen, indem wir
das Immunsystem abtöten oder reduzieren,
dann wird der Zugang zu Antibiotika natürlich
noch wichtiger,
weil man sich leichter infiziert und
dann Medikamente braucht, um die Infektionen zu behandeln, bei denen
sie gemeldet werden  Die
United Care oder andere Arten von Pflege, bei denen
Sie Patienten haben, waren extrem
verletzlich und zerbrechlich, sie haben nicht
viel eigene Abwehrkräfte, also
die  In der Lage zu sein, Infektionen zu behandeln, bedeutet, dass
sie sich im Grunde nicht selbst wehren können,
und die Behandlung von Krebs ist eine andere, bei der
wir Menschen diese extrem
wirksamen Chemikalien geben, von denen
Sie wissen sollen, dass sie den Krebs bekämpfen, aber es
bekämpft auch viele andere Teile des
Körpers  zur gleichen Zeit und zum Beispiel das
Immunsystem, daher ist es
extrem wichtig, Infektionen behandeln zu können,
sonst funktioniert diese Behandlung im
Grunde nicht. Es sind also nicht nur diese
Dinge mit den Epidemien, von denen
tatsächlich viel moderne Gesundheitsversorgung
abhängt  Zugang zu wirksamen
Antibiotika, um wirksam zu sein, was
gleichzeitig dann das ist, das ist
sehr einfach, dass jede Art von pathogenen
Virusbakterien auf natürliche Weise
resistent gegen jede Art von Bedrohung wird, der sie
in der Natur begegnen, das ist genau das, was
ihre Evolution ist nichts  Seltsam ist
so wahr,
also können wir das erwarten, und dann werden
Antibiotika unwirksam, aber
dann haben Sie diese Art von getan, denken Sie,
was in t  Diese Art von Rätsel ist gut
ok, um diese gut funktionierenden
Wohlfahrtsgesellschaften und Gesundheitssysteme zu haben, müssen Sie
Antibiotika verwenden, aber je mehr wir
Antibiotika verwenden, desto mehr werden wir
die Resistenzentwicklung stimulieren, weil
desto mehr Antibiotika in die Natur eingeführt werden
und diesen evolutionären
Druck erzeugen  das stimuliert die
Entwicklung von Resistenzen, also hier ist ein grundlegendes Dilemma
der Herausforderung, also
folgt jeder, dass jemand denkt,
dass ich nicht weiß, wovon zum Teufel ich
rede,
okay, gut, okay, also wissen wir, dass
dies so tief ist, wie mein medizinisches Wissen reicht
Wenn Sie technische Fragen werfen wollen, bin ich
nicht die Person, die diese beantwortet, eigentlich
bin ich nur ich bin nur ein Philosoph, okay, also
was können wir dagegen tun, nun,
eigentlich war dies die Reaktion
für eine ganze Weile, also lassen Sie uns  tut
so, als ob es nicht da wäre, richtig Ich nehme an, ihr alle
habt euch manchmal krank gefühlt, ihr
seid zum Arzt gegangen und ihr sagtet zum Arzt, gut
, gib mir nicht etwas, die Kopfschmerzen
wo  Geh nicht weg, ich habe immer noch Fieber
, mir etwas zu geben, wenn wir das
mit diesen Leuten richtig machen, aber du kannst
nicht viele Dinge tun, und im Zentrum arbeiten wir
daran, wie man dies und eines
davon macht  Was Sie natürlich tun können, ist,
dieses Innovationsproblem hier anzugehen, dass
die Tatsache, dass Sie keine neuen
Formeln von Arzneimitteln entwickelt haben, und
das teilweise eine technisch-wissenschaftliche
Herausforderung ist, weil es schwierig ist,
neue radikal neue Formeln zu finden, was im Grunde die
meisten neuen Formeln sind  Art von kleinen
Variationen der alten und dann ist die
Resistenzentwicklung sehr schnell. Der
westliche Traum hier ist natürlich, eine
völlig neue Art der Abtötung von Bakterien zu finden,
ohne Menschen zu töten, was eigentlich sehr
schwierig ist, also für jedes Medikament
natürlich das effektivste  - Je
höher das Risiko, dass das Medikament auch dem Patienten schadet, desto höher ist das Risiko, dass
das Medikament auch dem Patienten schadet.
Diese grundlegenden Dinge in der
medizinischen Forschung werden von uns zwar
technisch-wissenschaftlich unterstützt, aber das meiste davon ist
tatsächlich gesellschaftlich  tal und wirtschaftlich und
vielleicht auch legal, also werde ich
darüber sprechen, dass die
institutionellen Strukturen der Gesellschaftssysteme in Bezug auf
Forschung und Innovation geändert werden könnten, als dass
mehr neue Arzneimittelformeln schneller auf den Markt kommen.
Eine andere Sache, die Sie
tun könnten, ist der unkontrollierte Konsum
von  Antibiotika Dies wird
im Englischen oft als Antibiotic Stewardship bezeichnet.
Wenn Sie sich das whe ansehen, werden Sie
zum Beispiel lange Abschnitte
über Antibiotikum Stewardship haben, also ist dies
da, und was Sie dann sprechen,
ist die meiste Zeit der Einsatz von
Antibiotika im Gesundheitswesen  Pflegearbeit für
Gesundheitszwecke, also im Grunde, wenn
Ärzte Antibiotika oder
ähnliches verschreiben, werde ich mehr darüber sprechen
, aber Sie haben diese Sache
auch zum Beispiel in der Landwirtschaft, also denke ich,
dass dies ein großer Unterschied zwischen
Schweden und Deutschland ist, denke ich schon  denk in
deutschland darf man
optiken für wachstumszwecke noch in der
form verwenden in schweden ist es deswegen verboten
also das ist eine  d Ich weiß also nicht, dass Nordamerika
auf diesem Symposium vor ein paar Monaten
auf dem richtigen Weg ist oder dass es vielleicht
zu Wachstumszwecken verboten wurde, es
würde natürlich immer noch verwendet werden, weil die
moderne Landwirtschaft, insbesondere die industrielle
Landwirtschaft, viele Infektionen produziert,
weil Sie  halte die Tiere sehr
eng zusammen und so weiter und deshalb
wirst du sie sowieso mit Antibiotika behandeln,
damit du immer noch viel
davon hast, aber du kannst den Verbrauch kontrollieren,
ist natürlich eine, denn wenn wir
ihre Wache oder Zecken nicht verbrauchen können, dann
natürlich  Dieser evolutionäre Druck
, resistente Bakterien zu produzieren, wird
schwächer, sodass Sie eine langsamere
Resistenzentwicklung haben, wenn wir
vorsichtiger sind, wenn wir Antibiotika konsumieren,
und wenn wir dies nicht tun,
können wir natürlich auch versuchen, die
Ausbreitung resistenter Infektionen zu kontrollieren
auch darüber, damit Sie
effektiver erfassen oder überwachen können, wo
Sie diese resistenten Bakterien haben und
wer davon betroffen ist, und dann
können Sie anders vorgehen  Es
gibt keine bekannten Maßnahmen, die Sie ergreifen, wenn Sie
Infektionskrankheiten und Epidemien bekämpfen. Wenn
Sie also jemanden haben, der einen
resistenten Träger zum Beispiel in ein
Krankenhaus eintaucht, möchten Sie diese
Person möglicherweise aus dem Krankenhaus nehmen, um das
Risiko zu verringern  Dieses Bakterium breitet sich auf
die
anfälligeren Menschen aus, zum Beispiel
im Operationsbereich des Krankenhauses
, das ist ein sehr einfaches Beispiel,
und wir haben auch über diese Aktionen gesprochen,
dann haben wir eine vierte Art von
Aktion, mit der wir es abarbeiten, aber ich habe
gewonnen  Ich rede nicht so viel darüber, aber
das hat damit zu tun, dass aufgedeckt wurde,
dass ein Großteil der Emission von
Medikamenten im Allgemeinen, aber insbesondere von
Antibiotika nicht in der
Konsumphase, sondern in der Produktionsphase erfolgt
, also von den eigentlichen
Fabriken  Sie produzieren
viel mehr Drogen, als sie zugeben wollten,
aber jetzt haben die Leute gemessen und
so weiter, sie müssen zugeben, und ich denke, die
meisten der großen formellen Industrie jetzt
irgendwie  Ignorieren Sie das, okay, also ist dies ein Problem,
wir müssen versuchen, etwas dagegen zu
tun, aber natürlich haben wir auch
ein starkes Geschäftsinteresse und
alle sind irgendwie nervös, einen
Wettbewerbsvorteil gegenüber den anderen zu verlieren und
die Kosten zu erhöhen und so weiter  Es wäre
extrem kompliziert, gute
Richtlinien zu finden, die dagegen wirksam wären.
Ich könnte leicht sagen, warum
verbrennen wir sie nicht einfach und sagen, dass
sie die Drogen nicht abgeben können? Das Problem ist,
dass sie wahrscheinlich einfach
woanders hinziehen werden  und solange
wir kein wirksames globales Verbot haben,
wird uns das nicht so viel helfen, also werde ich nicht darüber
sprechen, weil es nicht
dieses Problem ist, das Teil des Problems ist,
aber nicht sofort im Gesundheitswesen erlassen wird
es bezieht sich nicht unmittelbar
auf die medizinische Ethik, obwohl
es sich indirekt darauf bezieht.
Okay, also aus ethischer Sicht, also eine
Sache, auf die Ethiker gerne hinweisen,
oder keine Konflikte, Wertkonflikte, und
Sie werden bereits ein Taubheitsgefühl feststellen  äh hier,
also gibt es hier mehrere Arbeitskonflikte,
interne, nur zwischen diesen Dingen
, die wir zum Beispiel tun könnten, wenn Sie
Innovationen beschleunigen möchten, möchten Sie den
Verbrauch nicht wirklich kontrollieren,
denn wenn Sie den Verbrauch für
die Droge
Honig kontrollieren, tut es das nicht  Es macht keinen Sinn, etwas zu
erneuern, das dann nicht verbraucht wird.
Wenn Sie also ein kommerzielles Unternehmen sind, das
ich entwickeln möchte, möchten Sie, dass
es richtig verkauft wird, und wenn Sie den
Verbrauch sehr streng kontrollieren, ist es
keine gute Idee, dies zu versuchen  dieses
Produkt zu entwickeln, also ist das ein sehr einfaches
kleines Dilemma, mit dem man versuchen möchte, damit zu
arbeiten, also können wir eine
Art Politik oder institutionelle
Strukturen konstruieren, die damit umgehen könnten, und
würde ein anderes bringen, ist
natürlich auch zwischen eins und nach vorne  Die
andere Sache also, wenn Sie wirksame
Möglichkeiten zur Kontrolle der Drogenemissionen haben,
wird dies wahrscheinlich die Kosten für
die Herstellung des Arzneimittels erhöhen. Ja, bitte,
in dem Sinne, dass Sie gut sind
Aber wenn du den Preis sicher nimmst, aber wenn du bezahlst, sinkt auch
der Preis für den Verbrauch
, also ist das auch einfache Ökonomie,
also
habe ich es in dieser Gesellschaft gelesen Punkt warte
jemand muss die Rechnungen bezahlen ja okay also
sage ich also dein Punkt ist okay  Hier könnte also unsere
Gesellschaft einspringen und die
finanziellen Lücken irgendwo füllen, okay
, aber dann müssen Sie die Entscheidung treffen,
dass dies eine normativ
wichtige Sache ist, und Sie
müssen eine stimmberechtigte Bevölkerung haben, die
bereit ist, die Steuer zu unterstützen  Erhöhung oder
was auch immer Sie tun müssten, um dafür zu bezahlen
, sicher, okay, ich stimme zu, ein weiterer zwischen
diesen beiden ist zum Beispiel, dass Sie, wenn
Sie viele Überwachungs- und
Überwachungsmechanismen haben,
Menschen von Krankenhäusern abschrecken könnten,
die damit Kontakt haben möchten  Gesundheitsfürsorge zu
versuchen, sie ständig zu überwachen und zu versuchen, sie im Auge
zu behalten, sie kaufen
ihre Antibiotika lieber online oder
so und dann haben Sie am Ende des
Tages weniger Kontrolle, also haben Sie
viel davon  Diese Art praktischer Dinge
, die schwierig zu handhaben sind,
und viele der Lösungen,
die in diesen Bereichen vorgeschlagen werden, um zu versuchen
, das Problem zu beheben, oder von der Art, die Sie
erwähnt haben, sind verschiedene Arten von
institutionellem, rechtlichem und politischem
Schlimmerem  moralische Lösungen, dass wir
eine Art normative
Struktur einführen wollen, die die Menschen zum Beispiel akzeptieren,
also werde ich ein wenig
über einige dieser Rechte sprechen, also in
Bezug auf die traditionelle
medizinische Berufsethik werde ich
darüber sprechen, damit wir'
Ich spreche jetzt nicht über medizinische Ethik. Ich spreche
über den tatsächlichen professionellen Konsens
, den Sie weltweit auf der ganzen Welt haben.
Ich spreche nicht über Moralphilosophie.
Ich spreche darüber, was Ärzte
durch die Fachleute und
Institutionen an sie gebunden sind  soll sich
irgendwie daran halten und dann natürlich
eine Menge Variationen in verschiedenen
Ländern, was sich
praktisch auf verschiedene Weise abspielt, aber nur sehr wenige
Dinge in dieser Art  sich wiederholen
, die auch
in diesem Zusammenhang angesprochen werden, so dass eine sehr offensichtliche
Sache, die Sie sowohl in dieser
Genfer Erklärung als auch in der
Forschungsethik finden, der Fokus auf den
einzelnen Patienten ist, so dass eine medizinische
Fachkraft immer der Arzt oder die Krankenschwester sein sollte
Handeln
Sie grundsätzlich aus Interesse zum Besten Ihrer Patienten
und so ist es das systematische
individuelle Bedürfnis, das im Mittelpunkt stehen sollte
und in späteren Jahrzehnten dazu gekommen ist,
mehr zu lernen, dass Sie sich nicht nur um ihre Gesundheit kümmern sollten, sondern
sie auch als Menschen respektieren sollten
und zwingen Sie sie zum Beispiel nicht, Behandlungen zu nehmen
, die sie nicht haben wollen,
oder ähnliches. Ein weiterer Teil ist, dass
Sie gleichzeitig den Menschen nicht irgendetwas anbieten sollten, für
das Sie
die Verantwortung haben, sicherzustellen, dass Sie das tun,
was Sie tun  Das Angebot im Gesundheitswesen ist gut
genug, daher wird oft in
Bezug auf die berufliche Verantwortung darüber gesprochen,
sodass Behandlungen gut motiviert sein müssen,
hauptsächlich weil sie es zulassen  Sie haben
zum Beispiel Risiken, also wollen Sie auch, dass
sie effektiv sind und es nicht riskieren,
um das zu tun, müssen Sie Forschung
betreiben, und dann kommt dieser dritte Teil, der Ethikteil der klinischen Forschung, wo Sie im Grunde genommen haben, also sagen Sie das, um das
zu tun  Sicherstellen, dass diese Rechnung nicht
Recherche betreiben soll, das bedeutet, dass wir
zulassen müssen, dass wir tatsächlich ein
bisschen mit Leuten experimentieren, dass wir
neue Dinge testen, bei denen wir
uns am Anfang nicht so sicher sind, ob das gut wird oder
nicht  ist notwendig,
aber wenn wir dies tun, sollten wir uns an
Normen halten, die diesen Patienten weiterhin
fokussiert halten. Wir sollten dennoch sehr vorsichtig sein,
dass wir den einzelnen Patienten nicht zu sehr ausnutzen,
um ihn zu sehr zu personalisieren, und dies
findet sich natürlich direkt in der
Erklärung von  Helsinki drücken sie aus, und
dann gibt es eine sehr grundlegende Sache, die
in diesen beiden und vielen
anderen Arten von Ärzteeiden und solchen
Dingen wiederholt wird, und es ist diese Idee, dass Sie das
einfach sagen, okay, also natürlich  Diese
ungewöhnlichen Dinge standen in Konflikt mit
anderen Überlegungen. Es könnten
wissenschaftliche Überlegungen sein. Es könnten
monetäre Überlegungen sein. Es könnte sein, dass
die Politiker wollen, dass Sie etwas tun
, das Ihrer Meinung nach im Widerspruch zu Ihren
beruflichen Pflichten steht, und dann sollten Sie
auf
Ihrer Integrität bestehen.  Darüber hinaus
sollten Sie sich an Ihre Ethik halten und sich beispielsweise nicht
an die Gesellschaft binden, und
dies ist ein sehr wichtiger Teil der
medizinischen Berufsethik. Wenn Sie
mit Ärzten sprechen, halten sie dies oft für
den wichtigsten Teil  hier,
dass wir unser Beruf sind, wir sind nicht hier,
um der Gesellschaft zu dienen, wir sind hier, um unseren Patienten zu dienen, im
Grunde so oft, was Sie
sagen, okay
, wenn ich also über medizinische Ethik
spreche, denke ich daran, also schauen wir uns
die erste Art an  der Strategie, die Sie
jetzt anwenden könnten, als darauf zu
reagieren, gibt es aktiven
Widerstand, der gut
herausgefordert wird  Was in diesem
Bereich vorgeschlagen wird, ist, dass es im Grunde genommen
darum geht, dass man Anreize
für Forscher und Pharmaunternehmen schaffen will,
schneller mehr Innovationen zu machen und so weiter,
und einige dieser Anreize
könnten diskutiert werden, ob sie nicht
effektiv sind oder nicht  Natürlich könnte
es darum gehen, Preise für neue
Entdeckungen zu schaffen oder finanzielle
Erstattungen oder Unterstützung anzubieten und so weiter, aber
viele Dinge, die diskutiert
werden, sind eher solche,
die den Weg von der Idee zum Produkt ebnen wollen
Viele ihrer Stellen
werden also von erstellt, denn wenn Sie
ein neues Medikament entwickeln, müssen Sie viele
Phasen durchlaufen, und es
gibt viele Kontrollmechanismen in
diesen Prozessen, von der Art der Identifizierung
im Labor bis hin zu einem Medikament
auf einem Markt weiterverkauft zu werden, ist ein langer Weg
, und so gibt es eine Menge
Bürokratie, also viele Regeln,
wie man eine Idee in ein Produkt
umwandeln kann, also gibt es so viel zu
tun  eine Ausgabe über das, was die Amerikaner
gerne als Abbau der Bürokratie bezeichnen, Sie
möchten die Regulierung in diesem Bereich ein wenig lockern
, also wurde dies in
anderen Bereichen versucht, zum Beispiel bei
sogenannten Orphan-Medikamenten,
also Medikamenten dafür  ist dr.  Durch
seltene, also ist es sehr schwierig, gute
Forschung zu betreiben, um zu beweisen, dass sie
wirksam sind, also könnten Sie die
Bürokratie abbauen und sagen, okay, aber wir werden
die Medikamente trotzdem akzeptieren, weil es ungerecht wäre, dass
diese Menschen sehr seltene
Krankheiten sind, weil wir sonst gewonnen hätten  Sie haben
überhaupt keine Medikamente für sie, also war
das die Art von Logik in dieser
Art von Argumentation, also wurde dies
auch in diesem Bereich vorgeschlagen,
es könnte sich um Sicherheit handeln, es könnte um ethische
Anforderungen an die Art und Weise gehen, wie Sie
Forschung betreiben  Versuche und alle
Arten von Ideen, Sir, das Problem
ist natürlich, dass das Band aus
einem bestimmten Grund da ist, und jetzt brauchte es einige Bilder
, um das ethische Band zu veranschaulichen, das
ich zum Beispiel haben könnte, wenn Sie wissen, dass er
viele Bilder hat  deformierte
Kinder, weil Sie aus der
Forschung Drogen kennen, die
Menschen schaden, also haben Sie hier natürlich die
Experimente und Sie haben
das schwedische Papierheimprojekt, bei dem
Sie intellektuell disa hatten  Ausgeblutete Menschen wurden
in den vierziger und fünfziger Jahren einer gewaltsamen sanften Untersuchung unterzogen, um zu beweisen, dass das Essen von Süßigkeiten schlecht für Sie ist,
und hier ist der
Toast der berühmten amerikanischen Tuskegee-
Syphilis-Studie
Natürlich können Sie dies nicht wirklich
tun, wenn Sie die Bürokratie abbauen, wenn Sie
die Sicherheitsbeschränkungen für
verschiedene Arten von ethischen Anforderungen lockern,
und
so weiter  ausgenutzt und Sie haben
das Risiko so erhöht, dass das Projekt
, das Sie für die
Nutzung von blauem Wasser auf den Markt gebracht haben, unwirksam wird, oder
, was ich sagen würde, war viel
mehr Risiken als zuvor, weil es
immer in der Größenordnung nicht binär ist  Sie
werden immer Risiken haben, also ist dies mehr
als Sie, wenn Sie die Bürokratie abbauen, wenn
Sie die Anforderungen
lockern, erhöhen Sie diese Risiken, und dann können Sie sagen, okay, also das würde  Das wäre
natürlich schrecklich, könnte man sagen, aber auf der anderen
Seite, wenn Sie diesen
Innovationszug nicht zum Laufen bringen, was wird
dann passieren, und dann wird der
zukünftige Patient natürlich mit sehr
unwirksamen Medikamenten dastehen, also sind das die
Kosten, die Sie haben werden  am anderen Ende
, das nicht so sichtbar ist wie der eigentliche
Patient, der vielleicht so die
zugrunde liegende ethische Frage zu sein scheint
, dann die, die die
gegenwärtig identifizierten konkreten Patienten oder
Forschungssubjekte
um des Willens willen akzeptieren oder einem erhöhten Schadensrisiko aussetzen sollten  von
zukünftigen noch nicht identifizierten vielleicht nicht
einmal nur bestehenden Patienten,
die den zukünftigen Zugang zu wirksamen Medikamenten sicherstellen, indem
sie die Bürokratie entlasten. Dies scheint
die Logik dieses Arguments zu sein, und wie
weit möchten Sie dies treiben,
weil Sie dies natürlich auch tun können
Wenn Sie mehr Bürokratie abbauen, haben Sie ein
Verfahren zur Förderung von Innovationen, aber auf der anderen
Seite haben Sie noch mehr von diesem
erhöhten Risiko, also ist dies natürlich eine
Art Handel  e-off oder eine Art
Abwägung ethischer Natur hat
zum Beispiel mit der Gegenwart der Zukunft zu tun
, also ist das eine der Spannungen
zwischen der traditionellen Medizinethik,
weil die traditionelle
Medizinethik oft sagen würde, dass man nicht
wirklich opfern kann  der
Pressepatient vor Ihnen für eine Art
theoretischen Patienten in der Zukunft, der
gegen die typische medizinische Standardethik
verstößt, gleichzeitig scheint diese Idee in diese Richtung
zu gehen, also ist die nächste
Strategie diese Idee, den
Antibiotikaverbrauch zu kontrollieren, und das
bedeutet meistens in  Länder wie unseres, in
denen wir eine Verschreibungspflicht haben,
also müssen Sie, um Antibiotika in die Hände zu bekommen
, zum Arzt gehen, der
Arzt muss Ihnen etwas diagnostizieren
, damit die Verschreibung eines
Antibiotikums angemessen ist, und dann bekommen Sie
das Antibiotikum so und in a
Gesellschaft wie diese, was Sie dann
tun möchten, ist, dass Sie die
Verschreibungspraxis im Grunde einschränken möchten, damit Sie
einen Arzt suchen, der Sie ist
Wenn Sie die Messlatte für Van höher legen, ist es ein lustiger
Arzt, ein Antibiotikum zu verschreiben.
Es könnte sogar für die wertvollsten
Antibiotika sein. Dieser letzte Ausweg, dass Sie
einem gewöhnlichen Hausarzt das Verschreibungsprivileg insgesamt entziehen, ist ein gewöhnlicher Hausarzt
Das Wasser, um das letzte Mittel der Antibiotika zu verschreiben, muss
der Hausarzt
um Erlaubnis von irgendeinem Komitee oder
so etwas bitten, also wird dies tatsächlich
ein wenig in einigen schwedischen Bezirken
experimentell gemacht, um zu sehen, wie das in der
Reihenfolge funktioniert, und das ist natürlich absichtlich
Dauer  Die Verwendung dieser verlorenen Resorts
muss in einigen Ländern sehr gut sein. In
vielen Ländern
auf der ganzen Welt gibt es keine
rezeptpflichtige Einrichtung. Sie können einfach
zu den Kirschen gehen und kaufen, was Sie
wollen, und dann natürlich der
erste Schritt  In diesem Fall wäre es dann, eine Art Verschreibungsinstitut zu installieren
,
und hier ist eine neue Sache, die
auftaucht, die Leute kaufen dru  gs online,
also haben Sie diese Art von Offshore-Markt
, das ist natürlich, und je
mehr Sie Einschränkungen haben, desto
wahrscheinlicher vergrößern Sie den Raum für die
Offshore-Märkte, und dann können Sie
über Regulierung und so weiter diskutieren. Eine Sache
, die darin sehr klar ist  Bereich, also ist ein
Teil davon aus medizinethischer Sicht sehr, sehr einfach,
denn jeder
unnötige Einsatz von Medikamenten besteht eigentlich darin
, Patienten einem unnötigen Risiko auszusetzen,
also sollten Sie sie nicht verwenden, wenn
Sie also nicht wirklich Antibiotika verschreiben,
nur um sicherzugehen  oder einfach nur,
weil der Patient sicher sein möchte,
in den Urlaub zu fahren oder so etwas,
und eines der Dinge, die Sie tun, und
das ist ein hübscher Grund, ist, dass wenn Sie
also ein Antibiotikum nehmen, wenn ich nicht
infiziert bin, dies bedeutet, dass dies der Fall ist  Dieses Antibiotikum ist
die Art und Weise, wie Antibiotika verwendet werden, dass dieses
Antibiotikum meine natürlichen Gasbakterien abtöten wird
und die einzigen Bakterien,
die in meinem Körper leben können, oder die
resistenten Bakterien, also bin ich jetzt tatsächlich
eingeladen r  resistente Infektion in meinen Körper,
also wenn Sie gehen, haben Sie das vielleicht manchmal getan,
wenn Sie Urlaub machen wollen
und ein Antibiotikum nehmen, das Sie zu
prophylaktischen Zwecken haben, das Sie nicht haben, und
das ist, was Sie tun, Sie laden die
resistente Infektion ein, so ist es
Aus romantischer elektrischer Sicht ist es sehr einfach zu
sagen, dass diese Art von Verschreibung
tatsächlich gegen die medizinische Ethik verstößt.
Sie setzen Menschen unnötigem
Schaden aus. Dafür gibt es keinen medizinischen Grund,
und dies ist ziemlich einfach und
aus gesellschaftlicher Sicht von  Natürlich,
welche Art von unkontrolliertem
Drogenkonsum eine Gefahr für die öffentliche Gesundheit darstellt,
denn alle Drogen
belasten den Körper auf verschiedene Weise, und
wenn Sie sie nicht unkontrolliert konsumieren können
, ist dies ein Gesundheitsrisiko,
also ist das ein Teil davon
Aber es ist auch so, dass, selbst wenn Sie
keinen guten medizinischen Grund für das
verschriebene Antibiotikum sehen, der
Patient einen sehr guten eigenen Grund haben kann, also ist
hier einer, dass Frauen über den
Herrn sprechen  Das Interesse daran, dass
Ihnen ein Antibiotikum verschrieben werden muss, liegt
oft darin, dass Sie schnell
gesund werden möchten. Warum möchten Sie
schneller gesund werden?
wieder in die Kita stecken können, um
wieder arbeiten zu können oder wenn man
selbst krank ist, möchte man
gut in der Gesellschaft wieder arbeiten können, dass wir
immer mehr ungesicherte Beschäftigung haben, also habe
ich einen sehr sicheren Arbeitsplatz  für
mich ist das kein problem also das einzige was
mir passieren kann ist dass mein akademischer status
ein wenig runter geht wenn ich
länger krank bin weil ich nicht
so viele artikel veröffentliche bla bla bla mit denen ich leben kann die
ich behalten werde  Meine Beschäftigung Ich
werde mein Gehalt haben, aber viele Leute haben
heute sogar in reichen Ländern wie
Deutschland und Schweden und den meisten
europäischen Ländern eine ungesicherte Beschäftigung,
so dass Sie sogar nur wenige Tage von Arbeitsstellen entfernt sind
, um Ihr Einkommen so natürlich zu verlieren
m  Oder Sie
haben solche Dinge, die Sie haben, dass die
meisten Leute es haben, also selbst wenn Sie
eine Krankenversicherung haben, die
Sie entschädigt, wenn Sie krank sind, wird sie
Sie natürlich nicht zu 100 % entschädigen, also
bekomme ich 80 %  Denke, wenn ich krankgeschrieben bin, komme
ich schon auf die Top-
Listen für ein paar Monate, aber wenn
du ein niedrigeres Gehalt hast, ist dein Leben gerade so, dass
du es gerade noch schaffst, dein
Leben gerade noch zu bezahlen  Wenn Sie
billigste Lebensmittel haben, kann selbst die
kleinste Verringerung Ihres Einkommens
katastrophal für Sie sein. Das bedeutet, dass
die Art und Weise, wie wir unsere
Gesellschaften gestalten, sich stark auf das auswirkt, was
hier im besten Interesse eines Patienten ist,
selbst wenn dort  Es gibt keinen medizinischen Grund,
diese Aktivität zu verschreiben, wenn Sie
eine Woche länger zu Hause sind und viel Wasser trinken
und sich warm halten. Die Infektion wird verschwinden.
Kein Problem  Art von Situation ist
es nicht  nur dass es auch
Ihr Einkommen behält und in der Lage ist,
die Kinder und solche Dinge zu unterstützen, also
sagen wir hier, dass Sie
hier die Idee, was das beste
Interesse des Patienten ist, nicht wirklich von der Art und Weise trennen können
, wie wir die Gesundheitsversorgung in einer
Gesellschaft kontextualisieren  und Sie können nicht wirklich wegkommen,
wenn Sie vor allem die
wertvollsten Antibiotika einschränken
, bedeutet dies zwangsläufig, dass Sie ein
höheres Patientenrisiko in Kauf nehmen müssen. Deshalb hatten wir
Michael Miller, einen britischen Arzt, den
er auf diesem Symposium angesprochen und
dort mitgenommen hat  Einige Beispiele für Pädiatrie,
wenn Sie sehr, sehr empfindliche
pädiatrische Patienten haben und
ihnen Antibiotika geben müssen, und dann haben Sie einige
Kinder, die sehr, sehr schwere
Krankheiten haben, also bekommen sie die erste Wahl
des Antibiotikums, dann haben sie eine
fast schwere Infektion, die sie bekommen  die zweite
Wahl dann haben Sie die fast und
Ernsthaftigkeit, dass sie die dritte Wahl
ganz unten in dieser Liste bekommen, müssen Sie
die Grenze ziehen, die Sie nicht entkommen können
Machen Sie diese Logik nach, wenn Sie also den Einsatz von
Antibiotika bei einigen Patientengruppen erhöhen,
obwohl sie krank sind, werden Sie sagen,
wenn ich die Wahl habe, Ihnen oder Ihnen
das Medikament zu geben, muss ich es Ihnen geben, und
Sie müssen es
Ihnen nicht verweigern, weil es so ist  gut für Sie,
aber wegen des Interesses der Gesellschaft
oder der öffentlichen Gesundheit oder des zukünftigen Zugangs zu
Antibiotika, und das scheint eine
unausweichliche Sache zu sein, aber wie und das
ist eindeutig Aufmerksamkeit mit dieser Standard-
Denkweise über medizinische Ethik
, die ich als Arzt habe  Ich sollte darüber nachdenken,
was das Beste für meinen
Patienten vor mir ist, wenn ich meine
Handlungen richtig mache, also geht es als Drittes
darum, nicht den Verbrauch,
sondern tatsächlich resistente Infektionen zu kontrollieren
- was hier also oft gemeint ist, dass die
Idee ist  dass Sie irgendeine Art
von Screening-Programmen haben sollten, also haben wir
das. Ich werde Ihnen sagen, dass wir in Schweden jetzt
diese obligatorischen Screening-Programme haben, also
bin ich als Bürger verpflichtet, wenn ich ein
Krankenhaus betrete, bekomme ich diese  s-Formular und
dann muss ich dieses Kästchen ankreuzen, wenn
ich die letzten sechs Monate im Ausland war,
gilt dies als Risikofaktor,
Träger einer resistenten Bakterienkultur zu
sein. Träger zu sein und betroffen zu sein, sind
zwei verschiedene Dinge,
also in einem höheren Maße  Risiko für Fürsorge und
resistente Belastung Richtig, die meisten
Menschen tragen resistente Belastungen, haben
nie resistente Infektionen, also ist es nicht
wirklich gut für mich, auf diese Weise gefangen zu sein
, es ist etwas, das im
Interesse der Gesellschaft an der öffentlichen Gesundheit getan wird,
dann können Sie dann Sie haben  Sie können natürlich
eine Art Anzahl oder Patienten auf
Resistenzen gegen die tatsächlichen Infektionen untersuchen
, um schnell
verschiedene Maßnahmen zu ergreifen, um die Ausbreitung der resistenten Infektionen zu bekämpfen,
und Sie können
dies auch in Bezug auf die Kulturen und
die Anzahl der Maßnahmen hier tun  Sie alle
sind eine Art restriktive Intervention,
also entscheiden Sie, dass Sie, wenn Sie ein
Ergebnis dieser Überprüfung
haben, eine Art Einschränkung der
Maßnahmen ergreifen,
welche Art von  Handeln Sie gut, Sie könnten
beispielsweise den Zugang zu Krankenhäusern einschränken,
und dies bedeutet natürlich, dass
ich als Patient im
Vergleich zu anderen Menschen weniger Chancen habe, spezielle medizinische Hilfe zu erhalten
eingesperrt zu
Hause Baby Ich könnte Anordnungen bekommen,
meinen Lebensstil auf verschiedene Weise einzuschränken Ich könnte
denken, dass ich mich regelmäßig bei den
Gesundheitsbehörden melden muss, damit
es viele Tests macht und sieht, wie
ich alle möglichen Dinge mache, die Sie tun  können
und all diese Dinge
sind keine neuen Dinge. Sie werden in
Situationen mit Infektionskrankheiten getan, wenn
Sie ernsthafte epidemische oder
pandemische Situationen haben, um zu versuchen,
diese Epidemie einzudämmen, aber natürlich
tun Sie es, Sie tun dies gegenüber
Einzelpersonen, aber es ist so  nicht unbedingt
im Interesse dieser Personen, sondern
im Interesse der Gesellschaft
und der öffentlichen Gesundheit, also können
Sie hier klassische Art haben  von
kommenden Konflikten und Sie haben diese bekannten
Risiken des Screenings, daran habe
ich ziemlich viel gearbeitet
Indem ich Leuten Fragen stelle, besonders
wenn es das Krankenhaus oder der Arzt ist, der
die Frage stellt, dann ist mein natürlicher
Gedanke natürlich, was mit mir nicht stimmt,
oder umgekehrt, wenn Sie alle, wenn Sie einen
Sinn für das Spielen haben, die richtige Antwort
auf die von Ihnen gestellte Frage haben  ein Gefühl
der Sicherheit, damit die Leute nicht die
Hilfe suchen, es wäre das Beste, wenn sie suchen würden, sie würden
sich nicht an die Gesundheitsversorgung wenden,
weil sie denken, oh, es geht
mich nichts an, es macht mir keine Sorgen,
diese anderen Leute, die diese
Resistenzen bekommen  Infektionen, es ist nicht Nate und
so weiter. Dies war ein bekannter
Nebeneffekt von Screening-Programmen, dass
Sie Stigmatisierungsbewertungen erstellen,
dass Sie ein psychologisches
Phänomen erzeugen, indem Sie den Leuten
Fragen stellen oder haben  Sicher, Sie haben also
Leute, die Träger sind, die bereits
erforscht werden, tatsächlich die trägerresistenten
Bakterien sehen, aber sie denken, dass
sie infiziert sind, weil es sehr, ich meine,
schwierig ist, die Unterscheidung zu erklären, und
es ist sehr schwierig für die meisten Menschen,
das Konzept des Tragens von
Gesundheitsrisiken zu verstehen  ist nicht das konkrete
Ding, die meisten Menschen haben eine sehr schwierige
Zeit damit umzugehen. Was bedeutet das?
Ich meine, jeder, der über
mathematische Statistiken verfügt, weiß, was
Risiko in diesem Konzept bedeutet, richtig, es geht nicht
um Sie, es geht um diese Bevölkerungsgruppe,
in der Sie zufällig sind  Teil im Grunde das
, aber für die meisten Leute haben nicht
wirklich mathematische Statistiken gelesen, und
dann haben Sie natürlich die soziale
Reaktion auf Stigmatisierung, so dass in der
Nachbarschaft das Wissen aufbewahrt wird,
also habe ich zufällig erwähnt, dass mein Nachbar
gut war, in dem ich überprüft wurde  Krankenhaus und
ich sagte mir, ich bin nicht mit zugenommen, weil
ich das den ganzen Tag nehme,
glaube ich auf den Kanaren, oh mein Gott
und am ende des tages spricht sich im dorf herum, dass
die anderen eltern
meine kinder nicht in der kita haben wollen,
klassisches beispiel richtig, also
passieren solche dinge ständig
und dann kann es natürlich auch
gesellschaftliche diskriminierung geben  am Arbeitsplatz
und so sind die Menschen, und
natürlich ist es auch
aus der Geschichte bekannt, dass
solche restriktiven Maßnahmen
im Zusammenhang mit Infektionskrankheiten
tendenziell restriktiver und
brutaler werden, als sie sein müssen  Warum, weil
die Leute, die
professionell mit der Durchführung dieser
Aktion arbeiten,
nur Menschen sind, also haben wir bereits
Studien darüber, wir hatten einige, Sie haben zum Beispiel den Fall von
Carbapenem-Resistenz in Göteborg,
und nein, wahrscheinlich nicht, es
tut mir leid, ein weiterer sehr ernster Widerstand ist
nicht vorkommen, tut mir leid, das war das
Falsche, aber sehr ernst, und diese
Personen wurden viele,
viele, viele Monate isoliert gehalten, ich meine das ganze
Tamtam  Diese Sache ist im Grunde so
völlig isoliert, und das ist natürlich
psychisch schädlich für diese Person,
aber das Interessante war, dass
Sie in dem Laden recherchiert werden konnten
und der Laden sehr deutlich
sehr schnell gehorchte, diese
Person zu objektivieren, also sahen sie dies nicht als an
Patienten sahen
sie dies als ein gefährliches
Objekt an, das sie irgendwie fassungslos
machten. Dieser Instinkt, den Sie in einem medizinischen Beruf finden, um zu helfen, verschwand sehr schnell, es ging mehr darum, dass sie sich mehr Sorgen um sich selbst
als um die Patienten machten, weil dies so
ernst war  Infektion, also haben Sie
all diese Dinge, die
passiert sind, wenn Sie Programme wie
dieses haben, und das ist bekannt, und
natürlich ist dies auch eine Art Aufmerksamkeit für die
traditionelle medizinische Ethik, aber
andererseits ist es wirklich so, dann können Sie
es auch  vertretbar ist,
Menschen dieser Art von Risiko auszusetzen,
diskriminiert oder stigmatisiert zu werden oder
in falsche Überzeugungen gelockt zu werden oder was auch immer i  Es
ist, ich meine, wir befinden uns nicht in der
Phase eines akuten Vertrauens in die öffentliche Gesundheit.
Wir versuchen, etwas einzudämmen,
das auf der ganzen Linie gefährlich werden kann.
Dies ist nicht diese akute Natur,
die diesen Toaster langsam hervorbringt
Meiner, nur Ballistamon, der am
Robert-Koch-Institut in Deutschland arbeitet,
hat es so bezeichnet, also ist es keine normale Art
von Störung, aber alles passiert auf
einmal und entsteht langsam Schritt für Schritt. Der
einzige Weg, es zu schaffen, ist natürlich,
diesen langsamen Prozess zu kontrollieren und das  ist,
was davon ist, und das ist eine zusätzliche
Sache obendrein, denn wenn die Leute
diese Art von Beschränkungen oder
Überwachungsprogrammen zu aufdringlich finden,
riskieren Sie eine Gegenreaktion gegen
die Richtlinien, so dass eine Sache, die
passieren wird, zum Beispiel ist, dass die Leute werden
weniger zufrieden damit, medizinische Hilfe
in Anspruch zu nehmen, denn wenn sie es tun, wissen sie,
dass sie überwacht werden und dem Risiko dieser Art
von einschränkenden Bedingungen ausgesetzt sind, also hier
sind einige allgemeine Bedenken, über die ich
nachgedacht habe  hier so aus
Sicht der medizinischen Ethik also diese Aufmerksamkeit
hier kann diskutiert werden Ich denke, wie
schwerwiegend der Konflikt zwischen diesen
Bedenken der öffentlichen Gesundheit und den
berufsethischen Bedenken ist,
aber wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass der Konflikt
schwerwiegender ist, dann können Sie das nicht  nun,
sollten wir die medizinische Ethik irgendwie
in eine standardmäßige medizinische Berufsethik umwandeln,
während wir daran arbeiten, und ich habe
einige Kollegen, die
ein wenig darüber gesprochen haben,
würde sagen, hey, wenn wir eine
professionelle medizinische Ethik haben, die darin besteht
Die Situation scheint mir, dass wir
, wenn wir uns daran halten,
unsere zukünftige Fähigkeit, mit der medizinischen Praxis Gutes zu tun, vollständig untergraben werden.
Was ist der Sinn
dieser
medizinischen Ethik?  Art von
Institution, dass sie aus Vernunft
Recht haben, also ist dies keine sehr moralische
Philosophie, oft Dinge über medizinische
Ethik als etwas, das eine angewandte
Moral ist  philosophische Sache, das ist zum
Denken als medizinische Ethik als eine
Institution, die wir für
etwas haben. Ich denke, das ist eine Art
interessante Frage, aber Sie tun es auch, wie
interessant das meiner Meinung nach ist, hängt davon ab,
wie ernst dieser Konflikt oder diese
Spannungen wirklich sind  das bleibt
abzuwarten, denke ich, aber wenn Sie die
professionelle medizinische Ethik ändern wollen, wie
könnten wir es tun,
um diese Implikationen von dem, was
notwendig zu sein scheint, zu berücksichtigen, um
auf eine Weise, die ich meine, medizinisch zu sein, gut für den optischen Widerstand zu kämpfen
Ethik hat sich schon immer mit
diesem Konflikt zwischen individuellen Gesundheitsbedenken
und Belangen der öffentlichen Gesundheit befasst.
Wir hatten immer eine
Art Handel, der oft rutschte, also haben
wir diese Büros sehr hochrangige
Ärzte, die zum Beispiel an der Eindämmung von Epidemien arbeiten,
und das sind sie
diese Art
restriktiverer Dinge zu entlassen, wir haben eine
Gesundheitsüberwachung der Bevölkerung, wir
sammeln Statistiken, Sie haben diese
Art von t  Da Sie andere Arten
von Strukturen haben, haben Sie sich dafür
entschieden, den bürokratischen Aufwand für die
Arzneimittelentwicklung auf dieser Höhe statt auf
dieser Höhe
zu haben
Vielleicht könnten wir es ein bisschen herunterschrauben,
also ist das, was
in diesem Fall wirklich interessant
ist, passiert. Ich denke, was hier passiert, ist, dass
dies eine Art Spannung zwischen dem Denken in Bezug auf die
Bevölkerung und dem Denken
in individuellen Begriffen ist  Gesundheit Es
bewegt sich innerhalb des Gesundheitswesens Eine
Art Standardeinrichtung der Gesundheitsversorgung Ein
Krankenhaus Ein Hausarztzentrum, das Sie kennen, wenn
Sie Ihren Hausarzt konsultieren,
normalerweise findet dies
ohne Bedenken hinsichtlich der
Ethik der öffentlichen Gesundheit statt, aber hier sind diese
Bedenken  Schlagt man in die Pfanne, wenn man
als Arzt das Rezept schreibt,
scheint sich die Situation ein wenig zu radikalisieren im
Vergleich zu vorher auf der anderen
Seite  d Es ist auch so, dass es auch aus
Sicht der öffentlichen Gesundheit ziemlich
wichtig ist, dass die Ärzteschaft
und die Institution des Gesundheitswesens
dieses Vertrauen bewahren können, das die medizinische Ethik, die medizinische
Standardethik
, ein wenig schützen soll, damit ich
schließe  bei manchen der
studien ist das auch ein arbeitsfortschritt im moment
also das sind ein paar stillschweigende
schlussfolgerungen mit denen ich im moment selbst spiele also eine
idee verbindet sich mit einem ehemaligen sprecher dass
man in letzter zeit horrend zu oze
zurückgekehrt war zu oft an angus in seema zu denken
Das ist seine Idee zu denken, dass dies eine
Möglichkeit ist, die
Herausforderung der Antibiotikaresistenz als Nachhaltigkeitsproblem zu verstehen.
Was also das Problem Ihrer
Antibiotikaresistenz ist, dass sie
droht, etwas zu untergraben,
das eine Ressource oder Kapazitätsentlarvung ist, die wir
auf diese Weise bewahren wollen  Wir können
über Nachhaltigkeit sprechen, wenn
wir also zu viele Antibiotika auf die
falsche Art und Weise konsumieren,
dann untergraben wir zumindest diese  s
Fähigkeit, in Zukunft sowohl Krankheiten
als auch Probleme zu bekämpfen, also wäre vielleicht eine Möglichkeit
, dass sie der
klinischen Medizinethik eine Idee
dieser Art hinzufügen, um zu sagen, dass wir die
Standardideen haben, die ich zuvor erwähnt habe, dass
wir diese Idee hinzufügen  dass das, was Sie tun,
um einem Patienten zu helfen, niemals etwas sein darf, das
, wenn Sie es auf alle Patienten verallgemeinern
und natürlich alle
Patienten nach denselben
Prinzipien behandeln sollten, unhaltbar werden würde,
wenn ich also
Menschen Antibiotika verschreibe, nur weil sie es
wollen  in den Urlaub fahren und nur um sicher zu sein
, wenn ich das tue, jeder, der danach fragt
, und wenn jeder Arzt dies tut,
haben Sie die Praxis verallgemeinert, die
unhaltbar zu sein scheint
und natürlich ein Weg ist, es
zu versuchen, wenn Sie wie ein Philosoph denken  Zurück zum
Anfang wäre zu sagen, dass naja hey das ist
eigentlich genauso universell, dass die
Prinzipien, die wir schon in
der Berufsethik haben, ihr einfach sagt,
dass wenn das Unileben das ist
mir  Aus ethischer Sicht ist es über
Generationen hinweg, also denken Sie an
die zukünftigen hypothetischen Patienten als
tatsächliche konkrete Menschen, so wie
Sie nicht einen der
Patienten im Wartezimmer töten würden, um die Organe zu entnehmen
und dem anderen Patienten in
Ihrem zu geben  Wartezimmer Sie werden
mit Ihrem Patienten hier in
Ihrem Wartezimmer nichts tun, was einem
zukünftigen Patienten in der Zukunft schaden würde, indem Sie
eine Option wegnehmen, die sonst vorhanden wäre,
also ist dies eine Möglichkeit
, dies in einigen zu untermauern  Eine Art
moralphilosophisches Argument, es ist eine andere Art, darüber
nachzudenken, und es geht darum
, wirklich so gut zu denken, was man tut, also
gibt es dieses berühmte Argument gegen
strikten
Egalitarismus  Sie
denken darüber nach, dass Gleichheit
genauso glücklich sein sollte, wenn jeder nichts hat
, wenn jeder alles hat, ist
das einzige, was zählt, die
Qualität, aber das Problem ist das größte
Die Leute würden sagen, dass dies eine
Art moralischer Unterschied zwischen diesen beiden
Rechten ist, wenn Sie die Sache gut bemerken,
fast jeder hat alles und ein
paar Leute haben fast
alles  Der Weg zu gehen, wenn
Sie so starr im
tyrannischen Recht sind, muss
etwas Ähnliches passieren. Wenn Sie sich also
an diese standardmäßigen medizinisch-
ethischen Prinzipien halten, entsteht auch in diesem Zusammenhang ein Problem
dieser Art von
kollektivem Handeln  Sie
untergraben tatsächlich die Ressource, die Sie
alle verwenden, indem Sie sich an die Regeln halten, an
die Sie sich normalerweise halten. Dann könnten Sie
auf viele Arten beschrieben werden, aber es passiert eine
Art
Irrationalität oder Nikolic, um
skaliert zu werden. Was machen Sie dann so gut
?  Sie können die Regeln, denen Sie folgen, so ändern,
dass Sie das Sammelaktionsproblem vermeiden
, und was Sie dann tun
müssten, wäre, es zu tun, um sie nicht
zu untergraben  die zukünftige Fähigkeit, Gutes zu tun,
aber das ist nicht wirklich so,
das ist sehr theoretisch,
was konkret zu tun ist, also eine Sache
, die sehr gut diskutiert wurde,
wollen wir, dass sich die Ärzte und die
Pflegekräfte in Krankenhäusern Sorgen machen
Sie wissen, dass man in Primärversorgungskliniken
über diese Dinge nachdenken muss, also ist dies die
Frage, die normalerweise auftaucht, wenn Sie
über das Setzen von Prioritäten sprechen, wenn Sie
über die Verteilung von Geldern für
Ressourcen im Gesundheitswesen sprechen
wo wir das
Geld in Gesundheitsressourcen stecken, aber wir
wollen nicht, dass die Ärzte
das in der Klinik tun, wir wollen, dass diese
Entscheidungen auf einer anderen
Ebene der Institution Anklang finden, und das ist
vielleicht etwas, das Sie und ich
am meisten gut finden  von uns würden uns
als Patienten nicht sehr sicher fühlen, wenn wir wüssten, dass
der Arzt, wenn ich ihn treffe, unter anderem darüber
nachdenkt, wie viel ich koste.
Wir wollen Ärzte haben  Tinte nur
darüber, was ich als Patient brauche, dann haben
vielleicht einige Leute im Ausschuss auf einer
höheren institutionellen Ebene darüber nachgedacht,
was Leute wie ich wie ich kosten.
Natürlich muss dies in jedem Wirtschaftssystem geschehen,
aber wir tun es
nicht.  Wir wollen nicht, dass die Ärzte das tun, also
sollten wir hier vielleicht ähnlich denken
, dass wir versuchen, alles, was sie tun,
um die Nachhaltigkeit der
Gesundheitssysteme angesichts ihrer
Antibiotikaresistenz-Herausforderung aufrechtzuerhalten
, auf
ihrer institutionellen Ebene durchzusetzen, aber
Ich denke, es ist notwendig,
die Daten trotzdem zu haben, die
Gesundheitsexperten müssen akzeptieren, dass
dies geschieht, also ist dies immer noch ein bisschen eine
Anpassung an die traditionellen
medizinischen ethischen Steine, und es ist
eigentlich sehr interessant, dass es
ziemlich weit diskutiert wird
Mediziner in verschiedenen Bereichen und
verschiedene Menschen reagieren sehr unterschiedlich
auf diese Art von Dingen, also freue ich mich,
jetzt Ihre Reaktionen zu hören, danke  u